us but dr. regular we have reached a
general agreement on the data regulation
as well as on the public documents
regulation these are two significant
decisions which are important to every
EU citizen we need to protect the
financial interests of the EU and it is
my strong believe that a PPO I may use
this abbreviation will be a very useful
and efficient tool that will help us
investigate and prosecute all crimes
related to you fraud there's this
karateka as concerns migration
challenges I can conclude that over all
Member States take a positive view of
the agenda on migration proposed by the
commission and it's a good basis for
further work there was a positive
assessment of an approach that would
include both immediate and medium-term
actions based on four pillars reduction
of migration flows improving border
controls strengthening the asylum system
and improving opportunities for legal
migration the european agenda on
migration is it finely balanced package
not an a la carte approach the proposals
that we have put forward are an
expression of solidarity and
responsibility